hey 42 here there is a tree called the
fruit salad tree that can grow up to
seven different kinds of fruit on the
same tree welcome to RIF Andre the Giant
Russa moth once drank a hundred and
nineteen beers in six hours he passed
out in the hotel lobby but was too large
for anyone to help him return to his
room so he slept in the lobby all night
if New York City where its own country
and the NYPD was an army it would be the
20th best funded Army in the world just
behind Greece and just ahead of North
Korea a whopping 90% of Mozilla's
revenue comes from a contract with
Google to be Firefox's default search
engine Madagascar was once home to an
enormous flightless bird known as the
elephant bird it was three times the
size of an ostrich at more than ten feet
tall they existed as recently as the
18th century there are approximately 3
million shipwrecks on the ocean floor
collectively worth billions in value and
treasure if you dissolve viagra in the
water of a Vaes of cut flowers the
flowers will stand up straight for a
week beyond their natural lifespan there
is a fruit by the name of black sapote
or chocolate pudding fruit which tastes
like chocolate pudding and is actually
low-fat and has about four times as much
vitamin C as in orange the human heart
can be replaced with two turbines
causing a constant flow of blood rather
than a pulse the Sun and the moon appear
to be the same size because of an
astonishing coincidence the moon is 400
I'm smaller but 400 times closer at a
cost of a hundred and fifty billion
dollars the International Space Station
is the most expensive thing ever built
thanks for the view subscribe for more